There is something inherently unnerving about
the sight of someone wearing a gas mask.
Maybe it’s the wide, soulless portholes
where a person’s eyes should be, or the
huge round filter extruding from their face
that makes them look like something inhuman.
It could also be the fact that, if ever you
see someone wearing a gas mask, you may be
surrounded by poisonous gas - and if you’re
not wearing one yourself, someone else’s
gas mask may be the last thing you ever see.
Whatever the reason, you might be wondering
why we’re talking so much about gas masks?
Well, that’s because you’re about to meet
SCP-1499, which is, as you might have already
guessed, an anomalous gas mask.
For all of you military history buffs out
there, SCP-1499 is specifically a Soviet GP-5
gas mask.
These were produced between 1962 and 1990
as a way to protect the wearer from the fallout
of a nuclear blast.
Back then, during the Cold War, an atomic
conflict between the United States and the
USSR - that’s Russia - was a constant threat,
and so these masks were sent to most of the
fallout shelters in the Soviet Union.
While the GP-5 masks could survive in all
weather and protect against radioactive substances
for a time, some of their filters contained
a number of harmful chemicals like lead and
asbestos.
The fact that these gas masks were airtight
would mean that somebody could end up inhaling
these toxic chemicals while trying to protect
themselves from nuclear fallout.
If you look up the definition of “irony”
in the dictionary, you may see a picture of
one of these gas masks sitting right next
to it.
And if you think that sounds bad, just wait
until you hear what sets SCP-1499 apart from
the rest.
Upon first inspection, the mask seems to still
perform its original function.
The filter works properly and the air-tight
seal is still formed when placed upon somebody’s
head.
However, when worn by someone, the anomalous
effects of SCP-1499 will also activate.
While it doesn’t fuse to the wearer’s
face and turn them into a hysterical zombie
chillingly asking for their mommy, the gas
mask does cause anyone who puts it on to completely
disappear from view.
Now, it is worth noting that this isn’t
a gas mask that grants its user the power
of invisibility.
If that was the case, this anomalous item
may actually be desirable.
SCP-1499 instead causes a person to physically
vanish, as in they are no longer detectable
at all.
Subjects that have worn SCP-1499 report that
they don’t feel any sensation of moving,
they simply put the mask on and end up…
well, we’ll get to where it is they go.
You see, through testing, the SCP Foundation’s
researchers were able to determine that giving
someone a two-way radio before they put SCP-1499
on means that they can still be contacted
after they vanish.
And it’s through these radios that the Foundation
discovered where the mask wearers go.
During testing, subjects have reportedly found
themselves in a strange, alternate dimension
after putting on SCP-1499.
It has been described as a dark environment,
inhospitable, barren, and filled with tall,
black tower-like structures.
You would think being unceremoniously transported
to another dimension by a gas mask would be
bad enough.
Just wait until you meet the locals.
According to a number of test subjects, a
group of humanoid entities inhabit this dimension.
Designated as SCP-1499-1, these creatures
are taller than the average person, completely
nude, and covered from head to toe in a coat
of a dark, viscous substance unlike anything
found in our dimension.
These SCP-1499-1 entities have also been described
as having too many mouths, and a large number
of eyes covering their bodies.
From the sound of it, the whole place makes
the Upside Down from Stranger Things sound
like a pleasant destination for a family vacation.
For the record, the reason we say “according
to a number of test subjects” is that there
has never been any photographic or video evidence
of this place and the creatures that inhabit
it.
All that we have gathered to date has come
strictly from first-hand descriptions of those
experiencing the anomalous effects of SCP-1499.
Luckily, anyone that puts on SCP-1499 and
finds themselves in this place has a very
quick and easy escape route.
Should a subject encounter any danger in this
dark, inhospitable dimension, then taking
the gas mask off will drop them right back
into our own plane of existence.
Upon arriving back, they will not have moved
from the spot they were standing in when they
first disappeared, but it is unknown exactly
how the gas mask is able to return them, or
indeed how it can send someone to an entirely
different dimension at all.
So, a gateway to another dimension, that’s
what the mask is.
The Foundation has been running tests on SCP-1499
since they first acquired it, at first using
D Class personnel.
The first test involving SCP-1499 saw a D
Class, D-67393, told to put on the mask.
When she did, she found herself transported
inside a building that was constructed from
an unknown black substance.
D-67393 surveyed the room she was in for a
few seconds, only to hear something moving
close by.
The sound caused her to panic, and she wrenched
the gas mask off her face, returning to the
test chamber.
Given that there was now a risk of losing
SCP-1499, the Foundation moved forward with
tests involving trained agents, instead of
D Class personnel.
Following this, the next test involved an
“Agent C” putting on the mask, and like
the D Class before him, he found himself in
the same dark room.
But instead of taking off SCP-1499 at the
first sound of trouble, this agent explored
his surroundings.
Agent C was able to descend the building to
a reasonable degree, until he heard sounds
coming from the floor below.
After hiding himself, Agent C witnessed the
very first sighting of the SCP-1499-1 creatures,
remaining undetected and then safely removing
the mask when the creatures had passed.
Another agent, known as Agent U, was selected
for an SCP-1499 test, chosen especially for
her extensive training in stealth.
Like those before her, she put on the gas
mask.
Instantly, she found herself in the place
where her predecessor had left off, and continued
the exploration of the building.
Detecting movement from the floors above,
Agent U exited the building and spotted a
number of SCP-1499-1 instances.
The creatures were mulling aimlessly around,
each sporting their own unique mutations,
occasionally uttering low, grating noises.
By now, if they were still using D-Classes,
they probably would have lost the mask and
the people wearing it a hundred times over.
Never get a D-Class to do a field agent’s
job.
Making her way past more of the tall, dark
structures, the agent followed and observed
a group of four creatures.
A fifth approached them, prompting one from
the group to step forward.
As Agent U watched, these SCP-1499 creatures
began violently assaulting each other, until
she too pulled the gas mask off and returned
to the Foundation.
Shortly afterward, one final agent, Agent
K, was sent into this alternate dimension.
This was less of a test, more a mission with
the purposes of reconnaissance, to give the
Foundation a better, clearer idea of what
the environment was like, and to possibly
even make contact with the SCP-1499-1s and
understand them better.
However, the outcome that followed could not
have been worse.
Agent K appeared in the other dimension between
two of the black structures.
The lighting made it difficult to see much
of the environment around him, but he remarked
that the ‘buildings’ resembled tall spires,
constructed out of hard rock, as was the ground
beneath him.
After a few short minutes, he soon spotted
a group of SCP-1499-1s entering a larger structure,
an elaborate building with a number of towers
and spikes on it, as well as what appeared
to be blood.
Approaching the building with caution, Agent
K located a small, secluded side entrance,
away from the larger front door.
As quietly as he could, he made his way inside.
The sounds of grinding filled the air from
all around him, as Agent K saw a huge group
of the mutated, humanoid creatures.
Each one had their mouth wide open, all of
their mouths wide open, making a chorus of
grating sounds.
The entities were, according to K’s description,
all facing towards one of the SCP-1499-1s
that was standing on a platform in front of
them, with a number of bodies around it.
This creature seemed to be leading an odd
ritual and began to cut open its own torso.
Wormlike creatures spilled out of the open
wound and a beam of light followed, projecting
out of the entity’s chest.
Agent K realized that this light was some
form of portal.
Another worm, like the kind that had come
out of the ritual leader’s chest, began
to appear in the portal.
Deciding to act, Agent K dashed out from his
hiding place, opening fire at the creatures
all around him.
He reached for something glowing in the lead
entity’s chest, which he thought was bringing
the worm creature through the portal.
Grabbing it, Agent K pulled off the gas mask
and found himself back at the Foundation…
holding a human heart.
But it doesn’t end there.
At the exact same time, on the exact same
date, a man attacked the Cathedral of Christ
the Saviour in Moscow, Russia.
During the church’s morning services, the
gunman entered dressed in a suit with a gas
mask over his face, and proceeded to shoot
ten civilians.
Six were killed, three left in critical condition
including the church’s chanter.
However, the worst occurred to the priest
performing the service.
The attacker ran to the front of the cathedral,
producing a knife which he used to cut open
the priest’s chest and remove his heart.
Then, just as quickly as he had appeared,
the assailant vanished before the eyes of
multiple witnesses, and Moscow police were
unable to find any trace of the man.
Officially, the cathedral was attacked by
Nikolai Orlov.
Undercover Foundation operatives inside Russia’s
media and military have spread this cover
story of a violent man who acted alone in
his attack on the church.
Meanwhile, the SCP Foundation is keeping Agent
K detained, questioning him about his involvement
in the incident.
According to him, everything happened exactly
as he described it, no church, no priest,
just him wearing SCP-1499 and surrounded by
the creatures.
The audio recordings taken from his exploration
mission also seem to align with his story.
But that still doesn’t explain how another
figure in a gas mask appeared in Moscow and
claimed the lives of multiple churchgoers.
Not only that, but dispatching them in the
exact same way Agent K dealt with the SCP-1499-1
creatures.
The only possible explanation was that Agent
K was the perpetrator, even if - in his mind
- he was still telling the truth.
Hoping to avoid another incident, the O5 Council
has suspended all further testing with SCP-1499.
Agent K has been scheduled to undergo a psychological
evaluation, believing the creature he saw
being summoned had to be stopped at all costs.
The other agents and the D Class involved
in earlier testing are all being brought in
for questioning as well.
It is still unknown what the anomalous effect
of SCP-1499 truly is.
Is it actually capable of transporting someone
to another dimension?
Or does it give a person hallucinations, that
make them think they’re galavanting off
in dimension X, while they’re actually walking
up to a church about to do something unthinkable?
With testing suspended, we may never know.
But it leaves us with an important message:
Think carefully about everything you do, because
what you think you can see doesn’t always
reflect what’s really there...
Now go check out “Robot Battle Royale SCP-1370
- Pesterbot” and “SCP-261 - Pan-Dimensional
Vending Machine” for more fascinating anomalous
objects from the SCP Foundation!